they're widely recognized phenomenon is
that organizations are on a pretty
regular basis walking back on the
promises they made to their employees so
they've caught pension benefits retiree
health care oftentimes people come in to
places being promised things that and
those implicit psychological contracts
are broken and that's not really news in
some sense on the other hand there is
this idea of a very powerful and
long-standing social theory social idea
which talks about the norm of
reciprocity that when you do something
for someone and particularly if you do
something nice for someone that that
person ought to repay the favor so if I
give you a ride you ought to give me a
ride if I invite you over for dinner you
should invite me over for dinner things
such as that and so you have on the one
hand this wonderful discontinuity
between organizations that seem to be
breaking promises and breaking they're
the you know not really rewarding the
hard work and good efforts that their
employees have put in but on the other
hand this norm of reciprocity
the intuition that we had is that as
soon as you put people into an
organizational context you told them as
opposed to a personal relationship they
were now in our organization instead of
a favor being done for them by a friend
that was being done by a co-worker and
things such as that that that would
change the dynamic in some fundamental
ways that would cause the favor the
person who receives the favor to feel
less obligated to repay the favor simply
because it was delivered in an
organizational setting and that's
essentially what we found now there's
some mechanisms that underlie this one
mechanism if you think about a
reciprocity means if you've done me a
favor in the past I should following the
normal reciprocity repay that favor
however organizations are not about the
past they're about the future and so
therefore to the extent that you are not
going to be useful to me in the future
are not going to be helpful to me and my
job of my career then I won't feel as
obligated to repay the favor in an
organizational setting because
organizations are both and are very much
about thinking about the future
organizations also prompt a more
calculative or strategic mindset where
you're always thinking about is can
somebody be useful or not going to be
helpful or that and so when you get a
favor done for you in an organizational
setting you're less likely to attribute
that kindness to some trade or
disposition of the individual and more
likely to attribute it to the fact well
they were just doing their job and that
also then diminishes the pressures are
the likelihood that you will repay that
favor because it's not really a favor it
was just part of their job